était ce soir emmanuel dupuy président
de l'institut prospective et sécurité de
l'europe
bonsoir emmanuel dupuis merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors on l'a vu
les attaques sur la zone verte de kaboul
ont été revendiqués par des chenils
profitent du chaos semé par les talibans
ont cette c'est quasiment impossible
mais ce qu'une alliance est envisageable
et sinon comment est ce que le pouvoir à
bord pour en profiter écoutez l'alliance
n'est paraît difficile puisque les
négociations de doha sautons pas mort
comme vous les images que vous avez
montré date et d'un certain nombre de
mois ça fait déjà plus d'un an que les
négociations entre afghane qui porte
très mal leur nom puisque il s'agissait
d'abord de négociations entre les
américains et une délégation talib al
bateen et ces dernières heures le prouve
de nouveau
je ne pense pas qu'il puisse y avoir un
accord dans la configuration actuelle
pour plusieurs raisons premièrement
parce que les talibans savent très bien
que la montre un joue en leur faveur les
américains quitteront plein kamistan
bien avant la date butoir du 11
septembre prochain deuxième élément les
talibans revendiquent et c'est une
guerre informationnelle qui se joue de
part et d'autre la gestion ou
d'administration de désormais plus de la
moitié il 10 81% on s'est peut-être sans
doute exagéré en tout cas ils sont
maintenant les maîtres d'une bonne
partie du territoire même si ils sont
partiellement les maîtres de ce
territoire puisque il conquiert des
territoires plus ils sont chassés par
les forces armées organe qui malgré tout
résiste tant bien que mal à l'offensive
actuelle des talibans
la montre joue en faveur des talibans
pour une autre raison de votre reportage
l'a bien montré la pression
internationale se fait forte pour que
l'on puisse accepter finalement cette
configuration qui semble somme toute
assez surréaliste un gouvernement afghan
est toujours en place alors que la part
la majeure partie des postes frontières
et des zones qui jouxte le territoire
afghan les postes frontières de spin
boldak
avec l'iran par exemple avec le pakistan
par vont paraître par exemple où les
zones frontières ou les postes
frontières que les talibans ont conquis
durant les deux dernières semaines avec
le tadjikistan le turkménistan où l'iran
prouve s'il en était encore besoin qu'il
y à des ingérences et une application
des acteurs du voisinage il s'est tenue
une conférence hack h 15 au cours de
laquelle le président afghan ashraf
ghani a nommément pointé du doigt la
responsabilité du pakistan le pakistan
du reste avait menacé les forces armées
afghanes si elle reprenait le contrôle
d'un poste frontière qui était tombé
entre les mains des talibans on voit
bien que pour l'instant la situation est
bloquée et comme un rapport d est ce
qu'on peut craindre justement que kaboul
et que l'afghanistan tombe sous les
mains des talibans et la terrisse ans
est déjà tombé sous les balles des
talibans
c'est déjà depuis de nombreuses années
pour plusieurs raisons quand on parle
des talibans donc qui parle t'on
vraiment votre reportage elle a montré
que ce matin les attaques qui ont touché
le palais présidentiel à l'occasion de
la prise de la prière de l'aïd n'était
pas revendiquée par les talibans mais
par une autre organisation qui s'appelle
l'état islamique khorassan qui est une
organisation qui ne souhaitent
absolument aucune négociation et qui
souhaitent défaire militairement les
autorités afghanes
quand on parle des insurgés est-ce que
l'on parle de 65000 à 80000 talibans
tels que on a coutume de les appeler ou
est-ce que l'on n'applique où l'on
n'oublie pas les débiles soldats 10
mille militaires ou personnelle en armes
miliciens entre autres qui étrangers en
tout cas qui ne viennent pas de
l'afghanistan la vie avoir notamment
créé vraiment fuyant le gouvernent c'est
finalement ce qu'on fit concerne à trois
parties bien distincts qui a les
talibans d'un côté le groupe etat
islamique de l'otan et les forces
afghanes
est ce qu'on peut craindre est-ce qu'on
peut évidemment s'attendre à une guerre
civile en afghanistan dû justement ce
conflit et cette issue politique qui ne
se trouvent pas dans ce pays la guerre
civile n'est pas induite par les
une politique qui est introuvable la
guerre civile est induite par le fait
que la communauté internationale a livré
l'afghanistan aux talibans les
etats-unis n'ont pas vraiment
conditionne mise en condition par dont
l'accord de paix en précisant évidemment
c'est le narratif officiel qu'il fallait
évidemment de mettre en application un
cessez-le-feu qui du reste n'est pas en
un pic mise en application on le voit
avec l'attak de nouveau de ce matin et
les attentats des derniers semaines et
des derniers jours on voit aussi
également que les taliban se montrent
particulièrement rétif à toute capacité
ou volonté de dialoguer avec le
gouvernement afghan précisant où on ne
souhaitant dialoguer qu'avec les
américains jusqu'à présent la
configuration tels que vous l'évoquez ne
se joue pas seulement à trois entre
l'état islamique les talibans et les
forces afghanes
il se joue aussi avec un certain nombre
d'afghans on évoque le chiffre de dix
mille billy ce qu'ils sont en train de
se monter à travers tout le territoire
pour essayer de t'arrêter ce qui semble
inéluctable non pas la chute de kaboul
mais l'arrivée politiquement acquis
actes et des talibans c'est la raison
pour laquelle les taliban pour l'instant
ne souhaite pas rentrer dans les
principales villes afghanes mais
souhaite qu' il puisse être adoubé d'une
certaine manière
reconnue comme faisant partie d'un
gouvernement qui sera exclusif selon
l'appellation coutumière mais qui
évidemment aboutira à la chute d'un
gouvernement
selon les termes que nous aucune faisons
référence c'est-à-dire un gouvernement
démocratique et accessoirement à
l'occasion des dernières réductions de
l'année dernière avec bien évidemment
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans à
kaboul mais surtout la manière dont les
talibans sont en train d'administrer les
territoires en dehors de tout centralité
on a trop tendance à penser
l'afghanistan comme un état ce sont des
vallées ce sont des légitimité locale
qui prédomine et c'est déjà
la raison pour laquelle les talibans
sont en train d'administrer une bonne
partie du territoire afghan
ça sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
emmanuel dupuis d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'institut prospective et
sécurité en or